Speaker 1: We have been starting to pay closer
attention to particular 2022 midterm races.
We're following just to name a few. The Florida
gubernatorial race where potential 2024 presidential
candidate Ron DeSantis is up for reelection
as governor. We on Monday night had a livestream
of in the Pennsylvania Senate. We first had
the Democratic primary debate and then we
had the Republican primary debate. The Republican
primary debate is the one where Mehmet Oz,
the TV doctor, is running. We covered that
and it was cringeworthy and it was wacky in
a lot of different ways. Another particularly
disturbing race is the Arizona House race,
where in in the first Arizona congressional
district, a guy named Ron Watkins is running.
We've talked about Ron Watkins before. Ron
Watkins is a a roughly 35, 34 year old conspiracy
theorist. He's the site administrator. Administrator.
And I guess we I think he's the owner as well
of the website 8-K, U.N. This is formally
a chan, and he has played a major role in
spreading all sorts of far right QAnon conspiracy
theories. He is now running in Arizona's first
congressional district. He was in a debate
last night hosted by Arizona State University
and the local PBS station. And there is something
about this guy that is cringe worthy and extraordinarily
creepy. I don't know exactly what it is. I'm
going to look at a couple of clips here with
you. First, just a very strange moment from
his opening statement where he kind of seems
to lose his train of thought. But it's all
just weird.
Speaker 2: And I will make sure that your
rights are are kept. Thank you.
Speaker 1: Okay. So the entire the entire
thing got off to a very, very strange start.
Now then, the question of Ukraine came up.
Military aid to Ukraine. Ron Watkins tried
to blame the Keystone XL pipeline for the
invasion. And this led to one of the other
candidates, Representative Blackmon, to basically
crush Watkins. And he crushed them so brutally
that Watkins had no choice to go. Actually,
I misspoke. My opponent is correct. This is
fascinating. Check this out. It's Harry aid
to Ukraine.
Speaker 2: What do you think, Ron? I support
the military aid to Ukraine. But I want to
say that we would not even be in Ukraine if
President Biden did not shut down the Keystone
pipeline in the first day.
Speaker 1: Why?
Speaker 2: Because now that that's shut down,
we have to get our oil and we're getting it
from Russia and we're getting all these problems
through the Ukraine. And that would not have
happened if Biden did not.
Speaker 1: See the Ukraine. So this is a word
salad. This is a no. He is visibly struggling
to use English to communicate substance and
he is failing.
Speaker 2: The pipeline helped prompt Russia
to invade Ukraine. Yes, sir, because we've
got all of this oil coming through from Russia
to the United States and they want the better
routes to bring the oil through.
Speaker 3: Can I can I clarify? This is what
I'm talking about. That's not why they went
in to reclaim Ukraine. They went into Ukraine
because Ukraine did want to be part of Natal.
Listen, you're trying to be you're trying
to work on a national stage and you don't
even know why the war started in Ukraine.
I had nothing to do with the Keystone pipeline.
The Keystone pipeline caused the inflation
and the increase in our gas prices.
Speaker 1: Now, that's that's also not true.
So they're both wrong. But but I mean, this
this is just bizarre.
Speaker 3: I went in to Ukraine because Russia
wanted Ukraine as they had them pre World
War Two and Ukraine wanted to be part of NATO's
respond police.
Speaker 2: He's right. I've made a mistake.
Speaker 1: Yeah, there you go. So, I mean,
listen, if there's anything to praise Ron
Watkins for here, it's that he immediately
said, yeah, what I just said is completely
untrue. It's it's absolutely and completely
untrue. In another weird moment, Ron Watkins
claimed that the biggest issue in the Congress
is it the first or second congressional this.
Now, I don't even remember that he said that
the biggest issue is the border wall, even
though this part of Arizona isn't actually
near the border. And then he claims that he
went to the border and scared coyotes away.
Coyotes, not literal coyote. Actually, I think
he means coyotes in terms of like people smugglers.
I don't think he means literal coyotes. But
let's listen.
Speaker 2: Biggest issue for this district
is the border wall. The border wall was not
completed and there are actually sections
of it that were destroyed. And I went down
to those sections and I asked the locals,
how did this section of the boardwalk get
destroyed? Right. And they told me that Biden
sent the Army Corps of Engineers down there
to destroy the border wall for flood for flood
prevention issues. So I went down there and
I saw with my own eyes I saw the coyotes sitting
right across the border. The coyotes looked
me in the eyes and they ran away.
Speaker 1: Right. They were so scared when
when Ron Watkins went down there. So bizarre
stuff. And lest anybody think that Ron Watkins
is the only wacky candidate. Then the moderator
asked Representative Walt Blackmon about his
history of wanting to charge people, women
seeking abortions and the doctors performing
them with homicide. And he says he still supports
that. So it's not only Ron Watkins that's
off the rails.
Speaker 2: I read that you have said that.
You said abortion doctors and women who get
abortions should be charged with homicide.
Speaker 3: Exactly. You know, that's already
in our statute, Arizona statute. If a person
commits abortion or kills a baby while in
the womb, it's under our criminal statute.
I didn't make the law that the law was already.
What I did was codify that law. Now, going
back and changing that and amending it, what
I have done is allow women to be able to seek
services, counseling services for what they
need. Now, here's the deal. The right.
Speaker 1: So basically, he's willing not
to charge women with murder if instead they
go to one of these counseling services where
the two, by the way, the term counselor, is
not a regulated term. It's not a therapist
where they go to like a Christian counselor
who talks you out of getting the abortion.
Speaker 3: There are more babies being aborted
in Born every day. Now, the problem that I
see is that that is not part of the conversation.
And if I have to do something to save the
black community of babies being aborted in
a record number, that's why I'm going to do
it. But we need to save all babies when we
have states like California and New York that
are pushing late term abortion, that are pushing
and fantasize, and we stand and do and remember.
Speaker 1: Know what? No one's pushing it.
Speaker 3: Nothing. It's time for us to take
a stand for life. It's time for us to get
on the side of God. And it's time for us to
protect these children that are being murdered
in the womb. Homicide. At what.
Speaker 2: Level? How far did the pregnancy
be when it's homicide? Conception.
Speaker 3: Conception. Conception? Yes.
Speaker 1: Can you imagine homicide for a,
you know, five week abortion? I mean, this
is this is some people don't like this term.
This is dark ages. Dark ages stuff. Okay,
one more clip. The moderator asks or want
two more clips. The moderator asks Ron Watkins,
how would you have reacted as a congressman
on the day of the Trump riots?
Speaker 2: I'll start with you. How would
you have reacted as a congressman on January
6th? On January six? As a congressman? I would
have texted President Trump and told him,
please call this off because it got out of
hand pretty quickly. Do you think he had the
power to do that? He did call it off, but
it took a while to do this. If he had the
power to call it off. Do you think he had
the power to call it on? I don't know. So
he had invited all these people out there
and surely there must have been some kind
of intell going on. But I don't I don't know.
It was meant to be a peaceful protest. And
there was some people that got in there and
did some bad things. And those people should
be prosecuted, the ones that did the bad things,
but right for the majority. Of the people
that were there, 99.99%. It was a peaceful
protest and there was no. So 99.99% of the
people that we saw on television storming
the US Capitol, walking the halls, defacing
the Capitol, these were. Well, I just told
you that there were people doing bad things
and there were millions of people there. And
there was just a few people that really I've.
Speaker 1: Seen.
Speaker 2: People at that rally and in the
Capitol. Millions. Yes, sir.
Speaker 1: Yeah. There were not millions of
people there, as, of course, we all know.
And then lastly here, Ron Watkins actually
asked about his relationship to QAnon. He
just denies the entire thing.
Speaker 2: Ron, some people say that a lot
of this was stoked by Cunanan. And what is
your relationship with Cunanan? I have no
relationship with Cunanan. None at all. Not
at all. The reports are that your bulletin
board sites hosted postings that launched
and launched a Cunanan conspiracy. So I ran
a free speech website and I was the administrator,
and there were many thousands, thousands of
people that posted on those sites. Q Was just
one of those, and I do not know who it was.
And I'm not that person.
Speaker 1: Yeah. And of course, he spent months
and months and months parroting Cunanan stuff
in cringeworthy fashion. So the closer we
look at a lot of these individual races, it's
all bad choices. It's bad and then worse.
And unfortunately, a lot of these people may
end up winning in November. We'll have these
clips on our Instagram at David Pakman show
who the for those who are gluttons for punishment
and want to take a look at them.